who do you blame for these insulin price
hikes well you know in the last 25 years
the pharmaceutical industry major
companies have been fined some thirty
five billion dollars for collusion for
fraud and for other illegal behavior
what we're seeing right now in terms of
insulin is the prices are skyrocketing
and just coincidentally it happens that
the three major suppliers of insulin
seem to be raising their prices at the
same exact time at the same level so I
think you have to be very naive not to
believe that there is collusion
we got millions of people in this
country who are suffering tens of
millions who are suffering from diabetes
six million use insulin we are spending
a fortune on the product it is rising
rapidly companies are making incredible
profits while people cannot afford the
medicine right now in my state of
Vermont people go across the border by
the exact same medicine they can buy in
Vermont they're getting it there for 50%
60% lower prices if those products can
come in they're the exact same products
made by the exact same companies if
those products get come into pharmacists
and distributors in this country we can
lower the price of prescription drugs
very very significantly the drug
companies have said that there are
various reasons for the price increases
that you know there are changes in their
drugs that the drugs are better that
they've you know enhanced them and
that's why the patents change I take it
from the look on your face you're not
buying it the drug companies major five
major drug companies last year made
fifty billion dollars in profits they
have well over a thousand lobbyists here
in Washington DC
they provide hundreds of millions of
dollars in campaign contributions their
job and what they do is charge the
highest prices they possibly can the
highest prices in the world their
business model is greed there are
millions of people today who cannot
afford the prescription drugs that
doctors prescribe senior citizens are
cutting their pills in half what the
pharmaceutical industry is doing is an
outrage their policies literally are
killing people who cannot afford the
medicine that is needed we need major
major reform in the fall
suitable industry given the lobbying and
the campaign contributions that you just
mentioned how much faith do you have
that the Congress the new Congress will
go after the pharmaceutical companies
historically they have not the
pharmaceutical industry is just too
powerful and between their lobbying and
their campaign contributions they own
the United States Congress and that's
why our people pay the highest prices in
the world for prescription drugs what I
intend to do is the work as hot as I can
with organizations and millions of
people throughout this country to tell
the pharmaceutical industry that they
agreed has got to end I mean they are
really a health danger to the American
people one out of five Americans study
go to the doctor and get a prescription
cannot afford to fill that prescription
that is crazy so we have gotta mobilize
millions of people to tell the drug
companies that your profits your
outrageous levels of profits are not
more important than the health of the
American people